[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this is the first of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude has just been escorted from the small fishing village of, I think it's, what is it called?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure what it's called.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eram.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's Enrar.
[SPEAKER_00]: To the gates of Monmurg, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, you got off the boat probably around 10 and he saw you and you went to him and he basically said, I'll take you to Monmurg's Gate.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's where you are right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if I remember correctly, you were basically saying to him, I want you to come in and talk to Lord Jamis and tell him what you've seen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it too late to have maybe asked if I need to get a hold of Olin Black from NRAR, if I need his services at all?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it too late to try to see if there's, you know, do I place up a flag over the end?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean like if, like I know he didn't really come to shore, but if I need to, if I need to go back or if I need to, you know, his services,
[SPEAKER_00]: He didn't really seem like he was gonna be contactable.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, once he dropped me off.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was my impression, but I wasn't sure because we did have that exchange where when he asked me if I was familiar and I'd mention that it was probably because he might know.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I told him, I said if you find them, she was looking for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said that if I found them, to remind them.
[SPEAKER_00]: The captain.
[SPEAKER_00]: That he was available for duty, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like the captain meeting counts, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, but no real way.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he kind of dropped us off practically right off the beach in the surf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty much.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, he took you aboard on a longboat, and you wanted to be as close to the village as you could, and people saw you get off, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So they knew that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I would like, what is this, the young person's name that's with me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it the son of the Tanner or is it the Tanner himself?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's Tanner himself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like him to actually come in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what do you say to him?
[SPEAKER_01]: I am happy to come with Costa to stay with your cart.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have somebody that I would like you to talk to and to communicate what you told me.
[SPEAKER_00]: And who is this person?
[SPEAKER_01]: Someone that it might be beneficial for you to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, I see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that acceptable for you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well here, let's walk to the gates.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, what was there, is there a card that we need to, probably we don't need to take this card in, but if we need to stable this card or something like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll see if we can get in the walls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they fortified?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, the gates are actually open, but there are guards there.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys get off the cart, and you and the Tanners, you don't really know.
[SPEAKER_00]: He hasn't really given it to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: How might I introduce you to Lord Seamus, should he give his audience?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that he should know the town I'm from, and I'll give my name to him if I feel comfortable.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is Ensar at odds with Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course not.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's in the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, yes, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wasn't sure if there was something... We know Prince Jeon, and we...
[SPEAKER_00]: Enjoy his protection.
[SPEAKER_00]: So anyway, you and Horace get off the card, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And Horace asks you, Jude, should I bring the wine?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, shit, how much stuff do we have to pack if I don't want to leave it on the card?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, basically you have that crate of wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there a dolly or something like that that we can rent?
[SPEAKER_01]: In the stables, wherever we leave his cart.
[SPEAKER_00]: So basically, Tanner says, I'm sure we can find a porter when we enter the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please, Horace.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bring the one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Horace takes the one out the cart, and the three of you start walking into the front gates, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll shoulder my backpack with my clothes and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, do you have your character up in Roll 20?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not in World 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: It never got posted back again.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we discovered that I had been exiting the game and that that had jacked things up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I stopped doing that when I log out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know how to log out now and not leave Journey of the Stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we never did get it posted up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a hard copy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see Jude here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do?
[SPEAKER_01]: When I go to it, let's see the character sheet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the character sheet the third icon in?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so there's character sheet, which is where I put the PDFs, and I see all three PDFs there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see marketplace purchases, there's premium assets, would it be in my library?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, no, so you will need to look at the...
[SPEAKER_00]: The journal.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, not the journal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, actually, no, the journal.
[SPEAKER_00]: The third one over, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, third one over.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, mine is blank, like, legit blank, straight up.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see your character sheet, and I open it up, and I see your character sheet.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see three PDFs.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see historical information for Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me do something.
[SPEAKER_00]: This might be the problem.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is, yeah, okay, so this might be the problem.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, here we go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Damn it, sorry about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You still there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I can hear you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I can hear you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think what happened is that when you reset it, the permissions on it reset as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just need to basically say you have access.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I am showing the first PDF to you, which is your main character sheet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now I am showing the
[SPEAKER_00]: Spell sheet to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I still don't see anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I might need to leave and then come back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, try and do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Try and reconnect.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dang it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not showing it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then let me actually try and get your character sheet.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you are still Stephen W., right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, Stephen W., period.
[SPEAKER_00]: The period after W. Okay, so... Now I'm doing the main character sheet, which I see you do not have, and I'll say can be controlled by...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, try that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I've given you access to the character sheet.
[SPEAKER_01]: There it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, let's go with that, and I'll add the permissions to the PDF because for some reason you can't see the character sheet folder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, like all I see is Jude now, so I just see my name, but when I click on it, it's bio and info, but it's kind of blank.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, like I don't see actually any writing at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so what you want to do is go over to where it says character sheet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I don't even see that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Up at the top.
[SPEAKER_01]: Compendium, jukebox, collection, my settings, art library.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you got your thing that says Jude, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's a plus sign.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or minus sign.
[SPEAKER_00]: You hit the plus sign, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And there should be a character sheet folder underneath there, a historical information for Jude folder, and then something that just says Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: All I see is the thing that says Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you click on that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It should pop open another window.
[SPEAKER_01]: It does pop open another window, but that window is blank.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I see bio and info, like a tab.
[SPEAKER_01]: It says Jude at the top.
[SPEAKER_01]: It gives me the option to print, expand it, but under the bio and info, it's like nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you can't see anything that says character sheet, a tab that says character sheet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just the part where I go in the journal and it says Jude with the bus sign, I click on it and then it shows me like a little character icon like an avatar thingy and it says Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it opens up the secondary screen that says bio and info but it's not filled.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, let me try something else.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, close what you have and then open it again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, there it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then open the character sheet, and then you have the core, the bio, and the spells.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, bio, info, like I have the character sheet, and then I have the bio, info, and the abilities.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now this is the cool part.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look down, you'll see things that say attack and spellcasting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that on my main sheet?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's on the main sheet you're on.
[SPEAKER_01]: The character sheet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, character sheet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, first of all, you see your hit points, which is 64.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a big number right in the middle, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep, yeah, I got that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look down two box rows, and you'll see this thing that says Attacks and Spellcasting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sleep, Fireball, Wall of Fire, Firebolt, Burning Hands.
[SPEAKER_00]: Double click on Burning Hands.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or just click on it, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, if you go back to the text menu, you'll see a thing where it says you clicked burning hands and it did nine points of damage, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, right on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Now go back to the character sheet again and actually if you look over at your skills, these are your things that are like saving throws, but you'll also see things like your stealth skill and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you click on stealth, it'll actually do a stealth roll for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's over by, let's see, stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I click on stealth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look at your skills slide.
[SPEAKER_00]: It says skills at the bottom.
[SPEAKER_01]: It says advantage, normal role, submit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hit normal role.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then it does a stealth roll for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why am I not seeing the roll, though?
[SPEAKER_01]: Look in the... You have to look in the... Oh, oh, oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I see what it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wasn't down at the bottom.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hadn't scrolled.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have to scroll all the way to the bottom.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, like, my stealth roll was 10?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that way I know you're not cheating.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so the thing is I'm not completely happy with the interface, but it works pretty well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what's nice is you can kind of go back and forth between the character sheet.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it's your character sheet, that's great.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also, it really has a lot of nice information, like you can look at darkvision and click on the darkvision trait, and it will tell you exactly what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it has a lot of rules that you can just deal with, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, I see that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there a place for me to actually keep notes?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, there is.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can create, if you want, like if you go to your Jude folder and you do add handout, can you do add handout?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right click on the top level folder.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I'll add a handout for you and rename it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm going to basically give you permission to see it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm going to call it Jude's Notes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm going to let you edit it, because it's yours.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you could have created this yourself, but I'm doing it for you so you can just go in there and add notes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So editable by Stephen and then you'll see that it is in Stephen's journal.
[SPEAKER_01]: There it is, Jude's Notes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep, so open that up and you can just type stuff in, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Hit edit and you can just, there's a place that says drop files and then description of notes and then I have an area where I put notes, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll play around with that a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so let's continue.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, like I said, roll perception, and the way you do that is you go to your skills, and there is a perception skill, and if you hit the perception skill, you want to do a normal perception roll, and you rolled a 13.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you guys are walking inside the gates, and you see the tanner kind of motion over to one of the guards, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the guard nods.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like as in just recognizing the tanner to let us through?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the tanner might be a little bit more than just a tanner.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or at least he's known by the guards.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's Monmurg who probably comes here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you guys walk into the, you know, you walk about 15 feet into the
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, into what is the front gate, which is basically on the way to the Great Market, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And what you notice is that it looks very, very anemic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Usually this place is bustling, but for whatever reason, there don't seem to be that many people out there hawking their wares.
[SPEAKER_00]: If anything, it's like people are trying to sell food, stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: This place is usually at this point in the year like bustling, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at the tanner with kind of a frown on my face and I point at the market.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long has it been like this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Since last year, trading season, the fall, basically the season's never started.
[SPEAKER_00]: The embargo has been on since then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Since fall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so real quick to the DM, what month is it now?
[SPEAKER_00]: This would be kind of like, this is like April.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so going into early spring and the trading has recovered.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's more like May and really the bartering should have started about a month ago, a month and a half ago, definitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so they've been under embargo roughly then for seven months, roughly, or eight months.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or basically what's happened is
[SPEAKER_00]: The trading season, because of the storms, shut down like they normally did, and they did not start up normally when the winter ended.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I see what you mean.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's not like they suffered a tremendous amount other than they're just off, everything is off right now, where it should be.
[SPEAKER_00]: Usually the training season begins about a month ago and starts into the summer and goes very heated into the summer and a little bit past into the fall, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, since I have your company,
[SPEAKER_01]: You usually request their presence with him at his office and he scheduled something with you, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, but we would have to go there physically, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm thinking, yeah, we go there, I make myself aware, and then we would head to Ferds because probably, I mean, unless they let us in immediately, we're probably not going to get an immediate eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Something like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: As I...
[SPEAKER_01]: As we're walking through the streets, is his offices, since he is the main ward or the main lord over the foreign district, is it actually in the foreign district?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's actually in the harbor district, at the end of the harbor.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you know, you would probably want to go there, go down to the harbor, and see what's going on there, and then go over to where his office is and talk there, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, the porter says to you, stay here, I'll get, not the porter, the tanner says to you, stay here, I'll get a porter for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He basically walks over along the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: He kind of goes off along the wall, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I mean, he's not trying to avoid being seen or anything, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no, not at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: He just kind of casually walks in the direction of whatever, you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I just make sure I notice if he comes back with a, you know, mob of angry guards or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at Horace, you said you've been to Monmurg before, but not with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is your first time, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, oh yes, this is my first time being down here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay, so you never traveled here when you did any merchant work?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, Gradsul was as far as I went, and I went mainly to Spindruth Isles, which is to the east and not to the west.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have to tell you, it's a sorry site for a market.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I can tell you it's a grand city.
[SPEAKER_00]: I swear, I've not seen so many rich castles and manors upon these hills adorned with jade.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's not gold.
[SPEAKER_00]: That has to be copper, though, at least.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm a little overwhelmed myself after spending a year in the War Torn.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, by the way, Monmurg is splendid.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, there's a lot of wealth here, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, presently, a troop of about 12 guardsmen walk up to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a channer?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And one of the guards says, Are you... What is your name, sir?
[SPEAKER_01]: My name is Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am just recently arrived by way of ENSOC.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this your servant?
[SPEAKER_00]: He points to Horace.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, my man-at-arms.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've been informed that you have been requesting an audience with Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought to go to his offices and to tell his man in front to announce my presence as Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see the Tanner walking back out of the gate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Out of the gate, like he's leaving?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, he just doesn't believe us.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rattled us out, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, yes, certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've worked for Lord Jamis before.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he well?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um...
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll take you to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: You two men, grab his belongings.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come with us.
[SPEAKER_01]: The wine is actually for Lord Seamus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please don't break it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's foreign.
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of looks at you like... Well, I look around and I say, I don't think you're getting much shipments of wine in recently.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, do an insight roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an insight roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they don't treat your wine roughly at all, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just trying to be like, you know... Yeah, you're like fussing over the wine, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, inside.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here we go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Submit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He kind of gives you a look like...
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know the kind of trouble you're in, buddy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm trying not to be all like, oh my god, I'm going straight to the brig.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, they're not gonna let me see Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're gonna be like, he's a spy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He just got let off in the waters across from Ensar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I mean, I'm more concerned about the wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I try to make that like it's no big deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have a whole foreign district just to keep us all pinned up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, exactly, pretty much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't see my insight roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: You rolled a 17.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: At the very bottom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very good insight roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: I make sure that I'm, like I said, absolutely relaxed.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they start to deviate us towards the jails, I mean, I'm sure I've had to bail Karmirg out of the jail before.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you know where the jails are, believe me.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll know if you're going towards it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would just like to make sure that we're going to Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, unfortunately, the jail that you know and Lord Jamis' office are one and the same.
[SPEAKER_00]: The one that Karmirg spent most of his time in was actually underneath Lord Jamis' office.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, I might actually, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: How fares the great city of Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: The market is glib and brim and I've recently traveled only to find out that you have an embargo.
[SPEAKER_00]: The guard says to you, this has been going on for a month at least.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's horrible.
[SPEAKER_01]: I came here on a shipping vessel from the D.D.
[SPEAKER_01]: to solicit funds for the war abroad from Lord Jamis and got waylaid and dragged into the port of Redshore.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's worse than the trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Port Torvin, where much of the food for the city this next month was coming from, up in the yeomanry, was attacked.
[SPEAKER_00]: By Gradso and Keoland?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or is the yeomanry marshaled against the crisis?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: The yeomanry was shipping the food down.
[SPEAKER_00]: We had paid heavily for it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Supply was coming our way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Supply ships were coming into Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not from the north, you understand, but along the coast.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought, okay, just to the DM, I thought the Yeomanry was like the interior, like to the east, or to the west.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Yeomanry is to the west, and actually Port Torvin, if we look at the map, which is right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, sorry, I still have my character sheet up there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Port Torvin is right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had thought that maybe I would have to come that way, like get smuggled.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Yeomanry is actually up the Houle River.
[SPEAKER_01]: Quite a ways.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, what he said was Port Torvin, where the food was stored, was attacked and burned.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that most of the supplies that were headed for Monmurg were destroyed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was it burned by Peoland and Gradsul?
[SPEAKER_01]: Duke Gradsul?
[SPEAKER_01]: When I heard that context,
[SPEAKER_01]: Was it in that context?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, obviously something happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was something related to the war, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: It wasn't very clear on who did it, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: The guard says, unfortunately though, without those supplies, people in the city are starving.
[SPEAKER_01]: Starving?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's already come to that.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you wish to talk to Lord Jamis, I would say you have him explain it to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just shocked.
[SPEAKER_01]: I spent many years here prior to my adventures abroad.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no food coming up from the south, from the Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: One would think that they would sell us food.
[SPEAKER_00]: We know they have plenty of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: However...
[SPEAKER_00]: For some reason they say they have run short.
[SPEAKER_01]: Has there been any direct attack other than Fort Torban?
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything on the Four Princes?
[SPEAKER_01]: I apologize, I apologize.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not on the islands per se, but I have heard rumors that ships have been attacked.
[SPEAKER_00]: I said too much to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: I greatly apologize.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is matters of state.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope that Lord Jamis is in good health.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so anyway, you guys march.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically it's about, I would say, a mile and a half march to where the
[SPEAKER_00]: Bailey on the Doxes.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is kind of where Lord Jamis hangs out, for the most part, doing his daily duty.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know where he lives.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, you do know that he's supposedly a rich guy, so he probably has a house in the Nobles District, which is on one of the hills, where Lord Jeon takes residence.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he spends a lot of his time here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you there still?
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, you back?
[SPEAKER_01]: Check, check, check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so basically just re-click that link.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to restart the Zoom, and maybe at one point it won't let us do that, and I'll have to send you a new one, but I think it's a good way just to get back really quickly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll just roll back up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do talk to whoever the sergeant is, and I say it was my full intent to have the Tanner talk to Lord Jamis as well, but perhaps it's unnecessary.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was just I was going to have him relate some things that he had told me that I'm newly returned to Monmurg, so we can fetch him at the table later.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, we can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so anyway, basically you march in silence for, I would say, what is about 30 minutes to where the Bailey is, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you are actually kind of concerned because there are more beggars on the streets than normal.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, there are beggars in the streets of Monmurg, no doubt about it, but they seem a lot skinnier
[SPEAKER_00]: Then you remembered them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Monmurg's beggars were pretty well taken care of, as it were, and that does not seem to be the case anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Things are getting pretty desperate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I notice any, like the shipping, like are the shipping bursts, are they just totally full if nobody's leaving?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the truth is, is what you see is you see the Monmurgian trade fleet, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is substantial, but you see no foreign vessels.
[SPEAKER_00]: And normally at this time of year, the docks, which are extensive, are bursting.
[SPEAKER_00]: But there is really no trade happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: And at this point in time, the docket, which is probably one of the most efficient in the world, by your accounts, is pretty barren.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you see every once in a while a Corsair, which is one of the military ships, slip through the bay on patrol.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's still going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do they have a man-of-war fleet?
[SPEAKER_01]: Besides just their trade fleet?
[SPEAKER_01]: Besides the occasional Corsairs, does it look like they're preparing to go to war?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, well, okay, so the, the, uh, Commodores of the Outer Islands all have their own personal fleets, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But they work together.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Lord Jamis himself has a squadron of boats, or actual ships, um, that he, he commands, but they have a, usually they are stationed in what's called, uh, the military base called, uh, Skull Island, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm Island, not Skull Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that the one that's kind of out in the middle?
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's where they kind of patrol around.
[SPEAKER_00]: But they'll patrol down the channel and whatnot, but normally they patrol out past the scimitars into the bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you don't know what's going on there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, just a lot has changed for the worse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, pretty much Monmurg's on shutdown.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So anyway, you get to the Bailey and the sergeant says, wait here, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And his 11 men basically stand there around the two of you watching.
[SPEAKER_01]: I ask if there's been a strict curfew initiated in the foreign district, just so that I'm aware.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of the guards says, quit talking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not in a nice way.
[SPEAKER_00]: I nod.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Raise an eyebrow and nod.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, the sergeant comes back after about 15 minutes and says, Lord Jamis has agreed to see you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your man, however, may not come in.
[SPEAKER_00]: He'll have to wait here with us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I grab the bottle of wine, or the box of wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Leave that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can tell Lord Jamis of your gift.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I take one bottle at least?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could you adjust your headset so I can hear you better?
[SPEAKER_00]: Put it closer to your mouth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that better?
[SPEAKER_00]: A little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: For some reason you're just a little, you're, you're, the volume's just not that much.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know why.
[SPEAKER_01]: Huh.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wonder why it changes so, so much.
[SPEAKER_01]: It starts out well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the thing is, it's not like you're adjusting a setting.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's subtle.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like your mouth is moving away from it sometimes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what's happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, it doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you walk into the baleen.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've been through this many times, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you walk down the hall.
[SPEAKER_00]: To what is Lord Jamis' room, okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's empty, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's as you remember it, which is basically fairly small but well furnished with, you know, nautical things.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a huge map of the seas of
[SPEAKER_00]: Seas around the Azure Sea, um, navigation equipment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, you know, Lord Jamis was a, is a, uh, expert navigator and has known in the past to be one of the guys that actually had sailed farther than most of the other, uh, Monmurgans had in his day, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So kind of a, a, adventure as it were at sea before he kind of settled down and, uh,
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically became the advisor of Prince Jeon, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the guy basically says, go ahead and sit there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I take my seat.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he points to the guest seat, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's not like trapped or anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, do you want to check it for traps or something?
No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have I seen a camera get tipped back over and shot down a chute?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you haven't seen that, but you have seen him be seized from behind and dragged down the corridor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you sit there, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I get up in pace a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_01]: I get up in pace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, about ten minutes go by, and then the door opens, right, and Lord Jamis walks in the room and says, huh, so you've returned from your journeys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I return in time of plenty and find when I come back that there's great hardship.
[SPEAKER_00]: What brings you back?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I had sought to try to wrangle Karmirg back from Gouge's clutches as the fighting in Idee goes poorly in his absence, and to discuss with you the possibility of a loan or some funding, perhaps, from the Sea Princes in order for concessions with Idee.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I'm not sure that the Sea Princes are in much of a position to
[SPEAKER_00]: He basically goes and sits in the chair across from me and says, Yes, times are hard for us right now, you've noticed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I had hoped to broker a deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have the situation in hand, or is it getting worse?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me ask a question of you first, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: D, what news do you have of it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there someone you serve there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know that I serve anyone except for your lordship.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I have taken a stake in Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, now this is to the DM.
[SPEAKER_01]: I believe that's, is it Onwal?
[SPEAKER_00]: Onwal is in... Onwal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Onwal is, yeah, in...
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a city of Granat in the nation of Onwal, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, no, I wasn't thinking Omnul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry, is it Omnulth or what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Omnulth Ogmonton, who's Peridil, is who you're talking about, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't realize that Peridil's name was Omnulth Ogmonton.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he, who's in charge of Edith?
[SPEAKER_00]: So Omnulth is the guy leading the armies, and literally he's the guy that kind of is commanding things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, and Lord Jamis knows Omnulth.
[SPEAKER_01]: He knows Peridil.
[SPEAKER_00]: Really, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's never met Peridil.
[SPEAKER_00]: He met Philo, who is Celeborn Landrovel, but that's it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, um, well, yeah, his name is Lord Anwar Bogmaton, and he
[SPEAKER_01]: However, against the south province, the Herzog of the south province, given the tidal wave that had devastated the coastline and the coastline communities, the south province, the Herzog,
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't believe that you met Lord Amla, but we became acquainted in Greyhawk City and raised a mercenary band of some four or five thousand.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're here for the half fork is what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would love to get to Halcorp, however, I mean, the need is much greater than that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, there are four funds, a small defensive mercenary band, concessions for, shit, I'll wait to the DM, what was the name of the city, the major capital?
[SPEAKER_00]: Naree.
[SPEAKER_01]: Naree, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I sought to bargain to see if the sea princes had any interest in having a trade negotiations and boldings in Naree.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was ready to discuss all of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm a little taken aback.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me first back up a step.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had to come here, obviously under guard, because I had to, my ship, the trade ship that I left Naree from.
[SPEAKER_01]: It went to Scant and then from Scant we took a merchant vessel.
[SPEAKER_01]: We were way late in the day by and taken to the Earl of Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: He had some 40 trade vessels and I knew things were not left.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've been in Red Shore?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've been, I've talked to the Earl of Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: I, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: What did you talk to the Earl of Red Shore about?
[SPEAKER_01]: I told him that I was an envoy from the D and said that I sought to treat with the sea princes for assistance.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so let me mention something really fast before you continue.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Every couple of seconds, Lord Damus is kind of putting his finger up to his mouth and moving his lips.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, it's a little distracting to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Continue.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, detect any magical...
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't... How are his eyes?
[SPEAKER_00]: How are his eyes?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, like, he's not being, like, magically manipulated.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not... Well, maybe.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think that he's looking at you intently and listening to you intently.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's like, every once in a while, he puts his finger, middle finger up, I mean, his pointer finger up to his lips as if he's kind of...
[SPEAKER_00]: He's holding it there, and it looks like he's mumbling, but there's no sound.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Jamis, as I said, let me be completely honest.
[SPEAKER_01]: So when the ship that I sought to come into the sea fences was waylaid, I named him the two brass ships that intercepted us.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was completely unaware of the blockade and thought to burn both the ships and the sea in order to reach you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Such was my haste to help Edith.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you talked to the Earl?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did the Earl ask you to assassinate me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that why you were here?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will know if you're lying, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: I keep my hands up.
[SPEAKER_00]: You put your hands up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, like I say no, and even if he did, I would not think of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so again he puts his finger to his lips and moves them a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then he looks at you and says, but the Earl did offer you something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: He offered me... Well, he simply said that they would pay greatly for someone who knew liking Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he asked me who I would treat with.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I said, being like, you know, previously in Monmurg, I said that since you lead the foreign quarter, I said, of course, that I would seek audience with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I begged in the same terms as an envoy, which got me an audience with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think that he thought that we were boozing buddies or anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he just sort of gave me a general, nondescript, you know, fancy ass, I would pay quickly, I admit to this.
[SPEAKER_00]: So basically he was asking you to spy for him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, or bring him more information.
[SPEAKER_01]: But then he was able to give me access to one of his smugglers, which dropped me off the
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I'm in black, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's whose ship my man in A-RAR saw you with, and who you exited with.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I hope that he told you that I sought to have him come in an audience, the Tanner, that is, who brought me to the front gate.
[SPEAKER_01]: I actually said that I wanted him to come talk to you as well, as I wasn't sure if what was happening in Ensar, silly me, I should have known that you knew all these things, but I thought that perhaps there would be some bit of information that you might need, as is, like I said, the countries that I complained to you of the 40-odd ships that I noticed.
[SPEAKER_01]: I come in earnest and I come in goodwill.
[SPEAKER_01]: Treated with you, you treated fair, harshly sometimes, I will grudgingly admit, but always fair.
[SPEAKER_01]: You never imprisoned anybody and didn't deserve it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Karma.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, he laughs a second and says, Yes, I see.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I had brought wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I will happily take a sip of your single bottle.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's Elvish.
[SPEAKER_01]: I brought it as a gift, but now it might actually be maybe the only wine that you've received in quite a few months.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is not true.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother-in-law brought me some just a week ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: Try it, shall we?
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes over and actually brings out a bottle.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we go into his office, or not really?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you're in the office, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay, okay, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and he basically just tings it out, and you can tell that his demeanor has changed.
[SPEAKER_00]: He seems to be a lot more relieved now, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he puts the two glasses up on the counter and basically opens up the top and pours you a good bit, and himself a good bit, and puts the bottle back down and says, Please, have a taste.
[SPEAKER_01]: To the health of you, Lord Jamis, and to the success of Monmurg in these difficult times.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I take a toast.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, I can toast to that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He takes a sip and puts it down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I just request of you
[SPEAKER_01]: My man-at-arms has been with me in fighting energy for these many years.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not currently being beaten in your jail, is he?
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course not.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I'll have him fed in the kitchens.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, wait right here, and he goes and pokes his head out.
[SPEAKER_00]: You hear him say, get the manservant of Jude a meal and make him comfortable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ale, if we have any.
[SPEAKER_00]: Closes the door and sits down.
[SPEAKER_01]: I sit down, too, and I say, when I talked to the Earl of Red Shore, I knew that I must be aware and informed of any of this, as the blockade was new to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, all that he asked was for information, but he only knew me as the envoy from the P.U.
[SPEAKER_01]: Treating, seeking Monmurg cash and monies and assistance and those sort of things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, he asked or he suggested that he would pay greatly.
[SPEAKER_01]: But of more interest, when I queried him, I was left with a distinct impression.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said that Duke Gradso is very serious about stopping the slave trade.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when I mentioned to him that four of the five princes
[SPEAKER_01]: The ones that he was largely embargoed around Conrad were not as keen on the slave trade and that it was the Tolis that maintained the slave trade.
[SPEAKER_01]: He seemed to sort of become irritated as if the whole focus was to defeat the four princes and then somehow treat with the Tolis independently.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was left with this distinct impression.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would not voice this to any but you.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it does seem that even women in arms say that the Tolis or Spindy were supporting you, given especially the lack of food coming in and the destruction of Port Torby?
[SPEAKER_01]: Torvin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't trust Tolis.
[SPEAKER_01]: I never have.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I've...
[SPEAKER_00]: I must agree with you.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are very untrustworthy people.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, there are a few you can trust.
[SPEAKER_00]: My wife, for example, I trust implicitly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I kind of choked a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: She is Suel.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you've never met her and I know your words were not meant to be insulting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, do not worry about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: But in truth, the Suel mostly stick to themselves.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have this honor among them where they, when they go into conflict, the only blood that gets spilt is Oeridian or other people's, not their own.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, in truth, I think you're...
[SPEAKER_00]: His insights into the matter are very adroit.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is true that Prince John has no wish to see the slave trade continue.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is purely a Toli matter, and the Duke of Gradsul's admonishment of it is basically an excuse to wage war on us.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Toli have been more than stingy with supplies, even though we've offered quite a bit of gold.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Duke of Berghof is known to have huge estates that make large amounts of food.
[SPEAKER_00]: Rice, as it were, not something that are to our tastes, as we hear like fish and meat more, and grains from other lands, but
[SPEAKER_00]: When a belly is hungry, anything tastes like nectar, as it were.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your insight is good, and I think you understand the political situation quite well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that the Toli, for whatever reason, has thrown in with the Duke of Gradsul, and they mean to squeeze Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why has Monmurg and the other three princes not Salad Vaughan?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll be honest with you, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: In normal situations, I would not trust to speak to you of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: But in truth, even though Karmirg and Gouge are useful to me, I don't think they have the insights that you do into the magical realms of things.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I need as many wizards
[SPEAKER_00]: As I can get right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: For the enemy we're dealing with is not just of bone and flesh.
[SPEAKER_00]: They control great magics.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's an artifact that has been taken from a small town in Salinmoor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Near a small town, not from a small town in Salinmoor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently one of the Toli, King Toli, has come into possession of a rare artifact.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother-in-law has spoken to me of this, and has told me this artifact allows him to control one of the turtle dragons from the Dragon Isles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do the princes not pay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, and we've paid our yearly dues to the turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no doubt about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do the turtle dragons not release there, Robin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Each turtle dragon does what it will, but of course...
[SPEAKER_00]: The deals we have made are with the greatest of the turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is the one that Cain totally has taken control of.
[SPEAKER_01]: This great dragon... No wait, to the DM, when he says, he said Cain totally?
[SPEAKER_00]: Cain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cain, as in, you know, Abel and Cain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so, is that from like...
[SPEAKER_01]: Port Toli?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, one of the sea princes?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you ask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, Cain Toli is an adventurer and a buccaneer, but he does come from the Toli family.
[SPEAKER_00]: He is among the nobles of that family.
[SPEAKER_00]: I must think that Sac Non Toli, the head of the Toli family, has endorsed his adventures, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now they cautiously ally with the Duke of Bradsoe and the large Keoland in order to defeat the Four Prince's.
[SPEAKER_01]: I say, my God!
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it goes deeper than that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So unfortunately, I will tell you
[SPEAKER_00]: That it's doubtful that the Sea Princes will be able to assist your small nation of Idee.
[SPEAKER_00]: I say this not because we would not wish to establish a trading port in that town, but I fear that in the summer Idee will be overrun.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well...
[SPEAKER_01]: Hence my haste in trying to...
[SPEAKER_00]: It will not be from the southern province.
[SPEAKER_00]: It will be from the Scarlet Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I slammed my fist against my thigh.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would suggest I came here on the ship thinking to offer Monmurg and the sea princes, with the exception of Toli, access to an marine.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're very faint right now, Steve.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's much better.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most unpleasant place where they are fortified, and I thought to offer Marie as a place not only for cordage, but also to keep an eye on the Scarlet Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother-in-law, who is actually quite
[SPEAKER_00]: High in the social circles of Keoland has told me of the threat from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's his idea, he's looked into it, and it is his understanding that the Scarlet Brotherhood has made inroads
[SPEAKER_00]: Into the School of Magic in Monmurg, I mean in Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not only that, but they seem to be in league with the Duke of Berkhoff and the Toli family.
[SPEAKER_01]: But like the Tolis and the Suel were circling their wagons, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe something
[SPEAKER_00]: Terrible as a foot.
[SPEAKER_00]: You may not know this, but the Toli family has been traditional enemies with the Rola, which are the family of the Duke of Gradsul, for thousands of years, well, for hundreds of years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now they are at least a very obvious loose alliance.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that the Toli have promised
[SPEAKER_00]: Lucian Rolla, the head of the Rolla family, something that he cannot refuse.
[SPEAKER_00]: A bride.
[SPEAKER_00]: A pure Suel blood.
[SPEAKER_00]: To continue his line.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would make sense if the Earl of Red Shore had said
[SPEAKER_01]: And I attempt to quote this verbatim, that once the onerous practice of slavery has been eradicated in the four princes defeated, they retreat with Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was stuck on the retreat part considering how I understand that Toli still largely pushes the slave trade and Jeon's perspective against it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is what I believe the intent is.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Duke of Gradsul, who is for all intents and purposes backed into a corner because, from what I've heard, no respectable Suel family will intermarry with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Over the last few generations, his family has been denied actual access to eligible ladies from the Nahili family or the Linth family, which are traditional Suel families in Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently the Nihili wished to destroy the Rola and have been doing so for generations now.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Duke is desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: He has no viable bride in the bloodlines and would have to take a lesser bride from one of the lesser houses if he was to continue his bloodline.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, it would reduce his authority as a great house.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the sequences never saw this coming.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, there's no
[SPEAKER_01]: The political gambit that we can play.
[SPEAKER_01]: The blockade's held by the strongest of its sea turd.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll see the dragons.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've got nothing better to offer than Blue Depressal.
[SPEAKER_01]: We cannot outmaneuver the Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: Listen, before you continue, let me...
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me pledge my allegiance, Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've worked with you, and while I'm still bitter about that ring of invisibility that you took from me many, many years ago, I do not hold it against you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps I can still entreat and best serve a D by serving Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: He opens up a drawer, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And he takes out that ring.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he puts it on the table in front of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, please have it back.
[SPEAKER_00]: You may need it for my purposes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The truth is, Jude, so desperate am I that I would take you into my service right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: And truth, I trust you more than I can trust anyone else.
[SPEAKER_00]: Possibly not as much as Karmirg or Gouge because their loyalty is without question.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, their intelligence is lacking in some cases and right now I need a scalpel as well as a cutlass to cut through this fog that is before me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you detect a plan formulating for some time?
[SPEAKER_00]: I have many plans and many tasks for you, but I should tell you this.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a war of spies going on right now, and I wish you to find out some things for me that I need to know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have to say that there's a man that interests me, for I do not currently know his true intentions.
[SPEAKER_00]: He actually came to see me and visited me.
[SPEAKER_00]: In Monmurg, about a month and a half ago, he was a wizard named Lord Phranck, who apparently has been given an appointment in Saltmarsh, a trading town in the south of Selenmore.
[SPEAKER_00]: By all accounts, very strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was trying to find out what was happening, trying to understand the intentions of the Duke of Gradsul, even though he was appointed to his position by the Duke of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: I couldn't really determine his true loyalties, but in Gradsul, very few people can be transparent, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother-in-law has told me, however, my brother-in-law is a man who is very well connected and actually knows the Duke of Gradsville quite well.
[SPEAKER_00]: He told me Lord Phranck had been appointed a very important office in Salonmoire as a secret inquisitor.
[SPEAKER_00]: For the Duke of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Investigating forbidden magic in Sollenwar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Specifically necromancy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently the Toli had had some dealings with a necromancer named Ixit.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Phranck was investigating this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this related to the item, the artifact that was found?
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently it is related to the artifact that was found.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're saying that the Duke of Gradsul wanted more information about this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure what the Duke of Gradsul knows even of what Kane Tolley's movements have been.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have struck a deal, but I'm not sure that the Duke truly understands how he is winning this war.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, our fleet would easily destroy those cows, the men of wars that the Keolanders sail.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, whenever we sally forth, a storm arises as the
[SPEAKER_00]: Dragon Turtles can make happen with their hot breath and steam, and our ships are attacked.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've lost three ships so far.
[SPEAKER_00]: After that, I've ordered them all to stay in port.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've tried to sally forth maybe once or twice, but every time, we definitely get intercepted.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're about to lose the link, Steve.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna restart, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you tell me when it's restarted and I'll click on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, you there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I can hear you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he says, yes, so when Lord Phranck came to Monmurg, I actually had, he was looking for me, but also searching through Old Town.
[SPEAKER_00]: He went and spoke to one of the alchemists in the old town and I had gouging Karmirg act as bodyguards for hire.
[SPEAKER_00]: I did this because I wanted to see how the Toli would react to Phranck.
[SPEAKER_00]: To my surprise they actually attacked him in
[SPEAKER_00]: On the docks, they attacked a ship with four Toli assassins.
[SPEAKER_00]: These men, these assassins, are usually used only for assassinations between great nobles.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they obviously thought of Lord Phranck as a huge threat.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I was able to convince Gouge and Karmirg to act as his buddy guards, and those two knife men were able to, with Lord Phranck and the help of Lord Phranck's sailor, kill the four attacking assassins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not before they were killed, however.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Phranck, I could tell, or Gouge could tell, because he was there, read the mind of one of the Toli assassins and learned of what Kane Toli had at that point.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is how I came to know that Kane Toli had found something in
[SPEAKER_00]: This is really the reason why Lord Phranck had come to Monmurg, to find out what Caintoli had taken.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the DM, is it Salinmoor or the Saltmarsh that Caintoli found the artifact?
[SPEAKER_00]: So Salinmoor is a province, Saltmarsh is a town.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So in the province of Salomon?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was Gowdor or Karmirg able to even tell you, after the assassination, would Lord Phranck spend most of his time?
[SPEAKER_00]: They followed Lord Phranck throughout the city most of the time.
[SPEAKER_00]: And from what I understand,
[SPEAKER_00]: He spent most of it waiting to talk to me and then he went into the foreign district and like I said talked to an alchemist.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was not here for very long.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have the alchemist under observation or is he still present in Monmouth?
[SPEAKER_00]: The alchemist is always under observation but the man is insane.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you know him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He lives in the middle of the
[SPEAKER_00]: Foreign District, as I said, selling potions and other things there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know of this guy, Steve.
[SPEAKER_00]: He actually is pretty crazy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge goes to him to buy healing potions and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yet, we had to go to Hempmona Land because this guy couldn't cure Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did Gouge find out when this guy had to go to Hempmona Land?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the guy that sent him to Hempmona Land to get the herbs.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a great deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been over a year since I've been here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you in control?
[SPEAKER_01]: You said that you didn't trust me, or you didn't trust many, and you're taking me into that confidence.
[SPEAKER_01]: How bad are things here at Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they on the verge of being out of control?
[SPEAKER_01]: You always have such a tight rein.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you worried about any other guilds or the Assassins?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they...
[SPEAKER_00]: The assassins are under control.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, Gouge murdered most of them years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: The city is secure, I would say.
[SPEAKER_00]: From the outside, but unfortunately I feel the city of Monmurg will tear itself apart before too long.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because of who?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are we not able to, if it is only one of the dragon turtles that holds...
[SPEAKER_01]: The chokehold on the bay are we not able, since we had paid the bribe, to start getting shipping to go around Jackson Island, past the Dragon Isles, past the ones that we had not bartered.
[SPEAKER_01]: Before I found Owen Black, who was actually...
[SPEAKER_01]: Suggested to me by the Earl of Redshaw, I thought to make a run for it from a merchant ship and go past the Dragon Isles.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I just...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the only way to safely pass into the Jerley Bay now is past the Horn.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that area is watched closely by the Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the Toli are, I mean in essence, part of the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli are very much a part of the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: They say they aren't, but we know they are.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're being choked from both sides.
[SPEAKER_00]: And truthfully, we do not have, we dare not challenge the Toli directly in Jirley Bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg has to have some advice.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I may be able to help you, and I can do my best, but as you said, the city is tearing itself apart.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I could be making all the progress in the world in Salamore or the Salt Marsh or any of the places.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, we'll come to that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do have thoughts on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, Jude, what I would like to say is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I found interesting about my conversations with Lord Phranck was not only was he interested in this artifact, he was also interested in knowing about the black sickness and for some reason very very interested in alchemy even though he apparently is an evoker.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's some strange things happening in Salinmoor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Things that my brother-in-law knows very well, very deeply.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's told me that Lord Phranck has a companion, actually a good alchemist himself, a gnome as it were, that was the assistant to the royal alchemist of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: From what I understand, this alchemist is looking for a cure of the blackness.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you ever heard of it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I need to go first here?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you really have never heard of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it anything to do with that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, would it have anything even like...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I'm thinking like black legs and stuff, but I just saw...
[SPEAKER_00]: No Jude, the black sickness is something that comes out of the swamps near West Keep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you ever heard of Riding the Dragon?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: There seems to be a cult that cohabitate with kobolds in the swamps on the Houle River.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've noticed them for, I would say, decades.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even centuries, they've been reported.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, lately it's gotten particularly bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, it's kobolds?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, real quick.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's who habitates with who?
[SPEAKER_00]: Human beings are cohabitating with kobolds.
[SPEAKER_00]: They drink a black liquid and then go into a dream state and hallucinate.
[SPEAKER_00]: But what's worse is once they come out of this state, they become fiends, completely driven and consumed by hatred of all living things.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother-in-law tells me, which is interesting to me, that this alchemist, this assistant alchemist, may actually be able to find a cure for this sickness.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will tell you truth
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother-in-law is quite possibly the most brilliant man that I have ever met.
[SPEAKER_00]: He speaks of this gnome, Sibu Baron, with reverence, and actually thinks him equal to his
[SPEAKER_00]: His peer, Edium, the Royal Alchemist of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so to the GM, is Cebu Bear, is that the name of the Assistant Alchemist?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: S-I-D-U?
[SPEAKER_00]: S-E-E-B-O.
[SPEAKER_01]: S-E-E-B-O, Bear.
[SPEAKER_01]: And... And what is his brother's name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you ask?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Jameson, I'm going to need to know a lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: A lot more than you're just telling me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You said that we are engaged.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or spies.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there is something that I can do
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Else, I'm concerned that you'll give me tidbits of information as you used to in the days of horror.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, unfortunately, I only just have tidbits of information myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I understand you do wish to know my brother-in-law's name.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I must meet with the crazed albumist, although you're right, I know him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would expect you to go and meet with the crazed alchemist.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I very much want you to do this.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are many people I wish you to meet and gather information from in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother-in-law's name is Zafar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar Azane.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is your wife's brother, therefore, Seul, and you trust him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I trust this man more than I trust anyone else in the world, besides my wife.
[SPEAKER_01]: Zafar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Z-A-F-A-R?
[SPEAKER_00]: Z-A-R-F-A-R. No, Z-A-F-A-R. Z-A-F-A-R, and last name again?
[SPEAKER_00]: Azane.
[SPEAKER_00]: A-Z-A-N-E.
[SPEAKER_00]: The thing you should know about Zafar is he's a good friend
[SPEAKER_00]: And courtier to the Duke of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: And is very concerned with the Duke's activities.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar is currently the head of transmutation in Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's also someone who used to act as head inquisitor for the office of forbidden magic in Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: This man has held many offices and he knows the secrets of both the Duke of Gradsul, Lucian, and his father before him.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is Zafar's suspicion that the Duke is being manipulated by the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Scarlet Brotherhood to bring about the destruction of the Monmurgian fleet for one purpose.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our fleet has kept shipments from the Scarlet Peninsula to Monmurg at bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli fleet is no match for ours, but
[SPEAKER_00]: We have suspicions that the Scarlet Brotherhood are shipping arms, men, and other weapons of war into the Duchy of Berghof.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our eyes are blinded, and we cannot see this, however.
[SPEAKER_00]: We cannot stop their ships, board them, and see what contraband they ship into the Duchy of Berghof.
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe the purpose of this alliance between the Duke of Gradsul and Port Toli is to remove the princes of the sea principalities as an obstacle.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's having help from the Plarve Westkeep and Toli Sagnon, the prince of Port Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: All of the Suel are working together, conspiring in some way
[SPEAKER_00]: To destroy the sea principalities and eliminate Monmurg and the Outer Isles as an impediment to whatever plans they have.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar is actively involved in ruining out and eliminating spies.
[SPEAKER_00]: In the magical academy in Gradsul, he's doing this under some kind of a pretense that there are necromancers and traitors from Salinmoor, uncovered supposedly by Lord Phranck.
[SPEAKER_00]: But in truth, he's looking for these agents of the Scholar Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_01]: And pets you need to trust someone like me from the outside would get a mage.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not Suel.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in truth, there are few Oeridian mages that have your abilities.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need someone that can look into magical things and find these out for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also, I need someone that can root out spies in Monmurg and determine the truth of things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, Monmurg must be intact.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're very faint now, Steve.
[SPEAKER_00]: A little better.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's almost like you have a wire that gets pulled out a little bit or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it might be.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of lame.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe I'll just get a different headset.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What would you have to start?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if I go to Sawmore or if I go to Hool and I search, I still would like to try to move
[SPEAKER_01]: Can obtain assistance from the Sea Princes should we all survive this.
[SPEAKER_01]: For a D, should a D still be a D in a year, in a year's time.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a considerable hatred for the Scarlet Brother.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, truthfully,
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I fear your small nation of Idee is already lost.
[SPEAKER_00]: By the summer months it will be overrun, like I said, not by the southern province, but by the forces of the Scarlet Brotherhood, who, by the way, will not stop there, but will actually overrun the southern province itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: If the Tsar is
[SPEAKER_00]: For my service, be you in the sea presence.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is possible for me to get a message to him, yes, even though he may not recognize it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have taken Karmirg's battle flag.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps that would be the bonefides that might get his attention.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would surrender that flag to you gladly if it would help the one message be delivered.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is Philo with him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, Philo is with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then perhaps what I'll do is send the message to Philo, as he knows me.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he can counsel this on Loft, one way or the other.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, the seas between here and there are not safe anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: And...
[SPEAKER_01]: If you but try, then...
[SPEAKER_01]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, where I would like you to start, Jude, go and see The Alchemist, as you've suggested.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please start there.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, there is another person that I would like you to go and talk to as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two other people, in truth.
[SPEAKER_00]: One is a spy that Lord Phranck had insinuated into Monmurg several months ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: An elf who goes by the name of Khalees, who actually has worked with some of my men in the past,
[SPEAKER_00]: She was able to identify a traitor that was working for the Toli and bring him to my attention.
[SPEAKER_00]: I had an inkling about it, but she was able to prove the fact to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was he also Scarlet Brotherhood?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he was actually one of my main
[SPEAKER_00]: Harbormasters.
[SPEAKER_00]: Someone I relied on heavily.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm afraid that he passed to the Toli the patrols of both my squadron and the admirals of the Outer Islands.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he was just paid for.
[SPEAKER_00]: I sent him to Gradsall, actually, so that Zafar could take a look at him, and he determined that was the case.
[SPEAKER_00]: When he returned, I thought it useful to be able to put him in Lord Phranck's hands.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I had Gouge and Karmirg capture him, with the help of Khaleesi, and deliver him to a pirate, one of the pirates, in Port Torvin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now this is where things become strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because even though I had made this deal with Lord Phranck, I believe the pirate that destroyed Torvin was working for Lord Phranck.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a saved Lord Phranck that was seeking to discover a cure perhaps for the black sickness?
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the truth is I have no idea where this Lord Phranck's loyalties lie.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're a good judge of character though, so this means that he had something
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, he's very convincing, but... Jude, this is what I would say about the man.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Zafar backs this up.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's very ambitious.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very...
[SPEAKER_00]: Very ambitious.
[SPEAKER_00]: And his loyalty seemed to lie with himself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar has talked to me and said, we need to have a way to exploit Phranck and make him spy on our side.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because he's very close to this Cebu character that I've told you about.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's the one thing Zafar seems very interested in, is making Cebu an agent of ours.
[SPEAKER_00]: The way through Cebu, Zafar says, is through Lord Phranck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because Lord Phranck, as powerful an evoker as he is, can act foolishly sometimes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then the third man is a merchant who actually worked in Selenmar for many years smuggling goods from Nundmurg into the city of Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_00]: He had dealings with Lord Phranck and has some insight into what's going on in Saltmarsh itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like you to speak to him to get a feeling for Lord Phranck and the other people in the area.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also to get a little bit of perspective on what had been going on in Saltmarsh before then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because apparently Phranck Cebu
[SPEAKER_00]: And the man who has been appointed the Plar in the area were sent originally to Salinmoor to investigate a group or cult called the Sons of Olad.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I believe this merchant may know something of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the merchant presently in Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the funny thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: The merchant was actually a Monmergian merchant who is actually quite a rich man, but ran his smuggling business out of salt marsh.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see, Keoland and Monmurg are
[SPEAKER_00]: Very much into taxes on one another.
[SPEAKER_00]: And goods that come from Monmurg were taxed at nearly 25% and vice versa.
[SPEAKER_00]: But this merchant had a way of
[SPEAKER_00]: Getting past that by selling his goods in Salimore as if they came from other places.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everybody seemed to turn a blind eye, but the Duke of Gradsul, however, sent Lord Phranck down there to stop the practice.
[SPEAKER_00]: This merchant was arrested by Lord Phranck in the Plar and questioned extensively.
[SPEAKER_00]: However,
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Phranck seemed to extort a pair of ships from him and let him go for 5,000 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let me just summarize.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Phranck is seeking
[SPEAKER_01]: And Toli agents.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the Merchant has some connection.
[SPEAKER_01]: Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though he's a Numburgian.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, he spent time there and I think he will give you a measure of who Lord Phranck really is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he Sue?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Merchant?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or Lord Phranck?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Merchant is an Oeridian mixed with, actually, men from the West.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, no, definitely as far from Suel as you can be.
[SPEAKER_00]: Friendly chab, actually, and quite bright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I like his company.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Phranck is definitely Suel, although he's from No Great House.
[SPEAKER_00]: And from what I understand, not really a lord, but a...
[SPEAKER_00]: Budding journeyman trying to make his way among the courts of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he is Suel.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's true, the city is becoming dangerous.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I would suggest is this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You take up residence in the old slum that you used to be in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ferds, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, Ferds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge and Karmirg come in and out of there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can meet with them if you want.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say pick up your old lifestyle, as it were.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will need, at least, when I talk to the elf, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Will she, does she need to know?
[SPEAKER_01]: Of my association with you?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: She will guess it.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's not unsmart about these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I have a feeling she will know exactly what you are up to in many ways.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, through her it is possible for you to get an audience with Lord Phranck at some point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is Lord Falk in Salamore or the Saltmarsh?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or is he in Monmurg still?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, what's strange is when he left Monmurg two months ago, he was actually captured by the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they took him to the fortress in the middle of the bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you sailed past it.
[SPEAKER_00]: On your way with Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was captured and kept there, and from what I understand, he managed to escape one night.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a very resourceful man, it appears.
[SPEAKER_01]: I came from the A.D. with some thousand little pieces.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no lack of gold, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: You tell me what you need as far as bribes go, and you'll get the money.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, if you're looking for food, you'll be on your own for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe I should take those bottles of wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would keep that, definitely, for yourself, and not sell them, but drink them down.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would appreciate it to be sure, but in truth, as I said, of course you'll not go hungry if you're working with me, but unfortunately the fare will be porridge and rice more than anything else.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can understand you need the fear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who is your man that I should talk to without bothering you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll have someone contact you at FURDS.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, in truth, I will have Khaleesi contact you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Khalees.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I will recognize her.
[SPEAKER_01]: How?
[SPEAKER_00]: She's an elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll know her.
Very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not many.
[SPEAKER_00]: Get a measure of her and I'll let her know that you're an old agent of mine and that she's acting as a cutout for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does she know much of Gaugher's armor?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like I say, she's said she worked with them in the past.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like you, I've been using her as a way to get information to gouge in Karmirg to do jobs for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I've been doing is trying to understand her loyalty.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm trying to make her think that she's one of my, I think of her as one of my agents.
[SPEAKER_00]: And really, I want to see if she'll feed information to Lord Phranck.
[SPEAKER_00]: In truth, Jude, I'm trying to set a trap.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you want Lord Phranck alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I want to turn Lord Phranck.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's something we need, some way, some leverage, we can get on him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if we can do that, he'll possibly be able to get us into the mind of the Duke of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_01]: I may need to be able to
[SPEAKER_01]: No, absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if I meet somebody, let's say, a crazy alchemist who needs to be questioned more deeply, more privately, not just simply in some back alley with ravens and bantons and a lot of it all, I could drag him into first.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you remember one thumb?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I?
[SPEAKER_00]: He was actually Lord Jamis' torturer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that's a couple.
[SPEAKER_01]: I probably do.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the guy that was going to cut off Karmorik's balls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably without even showing any excitement or distaste.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, get a message to me through Khaleesi, basically saying that you need the services of, well, there's a man to be questioned, someone to be questioned, and I'll send one thumb around to Ferds to help you with whatever you need.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are places inside the city that one thun maintains for just such activities.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if I read you correctly, police, we all police is to be ever tested.
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: So in truth, Jude, I want her to think that I trust her more than I trust you.
[SPEAKER_00]: To gauge her loyalties.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it looks as if you are betraying me and she doesn't report it, I'll know where her true loyalty lies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rest assured that I will do something shady just so that you know if it doesn't come to you or if it comes to you by an alternate source.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you need this, if I'm in doubt, send one Dunn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Send one Dunn to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unvidden.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know that you are not certain, and I will be able to present evidence of what I've given you.
[SPEAKER_01]: This war of spies, oh, this is my
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, Steve, we're about to lose the session.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I have to go to bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sounds good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good place to stop.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I hope it was entertaining.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no, very much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you still recording?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because my note-taking is a little bit delayed, so is it okay when I'm able to ask you, like, you know...
[SPEAKER_00]: I can actually send you the audio.
[SPEAKER_01]: That'd be awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you can listen to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't do that if you're playing with other player characters, but if it's just an NPC, I'll let you listen to it.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will talk to you later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bye.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bye-bye.